genn
was a child prodigy
he wrestled with tekken's elite while he
was still in middle school
it's because he made an adjustment mean
he lost him earlier this
is just that was obliterated wow
that's the end of that third place for
out he was supposed to be the next
great tekken god but then
he disappeared and now
genn's back and he's put the tekken
world
on notice
[Music]
gen is one of the hottest names in
japanese tekken over the last two years
he's made waves
beating some of the biggest names in the
scene and for many
that would be impressive enough on its
own but what makes it truly crazy
is that genn has been doing this since
he was a kid
i can get
[Applause]
started playing tekken when he was just
six years old first trying out the game
at a local arcade
he quickly learned just how frustrating
playing in an arcade can be
he threw a thousand yen in the machine
only to lose and go home
but genn persevered learning how to play
the game by diligently watching
other players hands at the arcane and he
steadily improved eventually making his
way to tournaments
he started out at smaller local events
like pizza matari before working his way
up to tokyo tournaments like
mastercup
when he was just 12 genn's team made the
top
four of master cup 5 and then the finals
of master cup 6.
by then the people who were beating him
were tekken legends like kudans
gen quickly gained notoriety in japan
for being so skilled at such a young age
he even got on tv for it
[Music]
and being that good at tekken at such a
young age really was a big
deal even back then most of tekken's
elite were older players
these days some of them are in their 30s
so genn
a teenager who could beat people who'd
been playing the game for his entire
life was
kind of incredible after finding success
in japan genn took the logical next step
and went international he and his father
who had been his training partner since
day one
flew to las vegas for evo 2014. all
right oh this is going to be a good one
so okay
mcp gen kids mcp standing for master cup
he's gonna be uh
going up against incog yeah for those of
you who don't know master cup is a huge
tekken tournament they pull
500 entrants every time uh in japan you
guys
keep your eyes open for that shout out
to master cup out there supporting their
players
genn arrived at the biggest fighting
game tournament in the world
wanting to prove that he was one of the
best tekken players on earth
and boy did he ever den is about to 3-0
out
after al put him in losers
that is crazy ken really showing his
ability to adapt
and you know what's crazy is i mean it's
it's because he made an adjustment i
mean
earlier this is just that was
obliterated
13 year old genn made it all the way to
the grand finals of evo
losing in a close match to jdcr one of
the best tekken players of
all time jen is definitely changing up
his pixels right now oh
huge mystic oh my god that looked like
it was going to be a drop combo bite
jdcr steps on him and jd
39 and we have a new evolution
champion jdcr and after his evo finals
appearance
genn continued to play competitively for
the next three years he clashed with
tekken's titans again
and again at tournaments like mastercup
and king of the iron fist
this to me is the wild card player of
this tournament everyone's looking at me
everyone's looking at novi but to me dan
is the wild card
keep an eye on this kid he is he pushes
the pace
every match he's so aggressive and and
so young all the japanese players say so
young so fast
but in 2018 ken disappeared
all of a sudden he wasn't competing in
tournaments he wasn't even playing on a
line
see in 2018 genn entered his last year
of high school which
meant that japanese university entrance
exams were coming up
so in order to get into the university
of his choice
gen had to give up his passion and turn
to studying
he stopped playing tekken completely
genn returned to tekken in 2019 and
while things were difficult at first
his love for the game and competition
gave him the drive he needed to regain
his old form
and in may he got a huge opportunity
being on team liquid allowed him to
juggle school and competition
without all the annoying logistics that
come with pro-life
and just a few weeks after the signing
genn entered his first tournament with
liquid
but the cool thing about this match is
again like i said battle of generations
dennis only 18 years old he just
graduated high school a couple months
ago
kuroko is over two times stage this is
somebody who's been playing tekken since
second one
going up against somebody who's been
playing since he was since he was one
essentially right raised in that
household that's amazing a pure tekken
player
genn finished top eight of the 2019
taipei major and
he kept competing trying to get his name
back out there after he
literally dropped off the map
oh
moving on on that winter side but man
again is looking
good oh down for one i can't wait for my
hair to get long i swear to god
all day and that was against favor tries
to retell it with a while running one
not a lot of damage but look at the
pressure coming from pickles he has to
make something happen and he's going for
big damage he needs something big
pickles under pressure now
less than half a bar
and again just too good genn didn't win
anything big in 2019 but he did pick up
some really solid placements like a top
16 finish at evo
he also placed third at the rev major
where he beat out huge names like jdcr
and chikuri is in big trouble
is it gonna be perfect oh my god he went
for the money didn't get it
again going to the winner final 2019
marked gen's return to competition but
2020 was his true coming of age gen's
first tournament of the new year was evo
japan
and at a tournament filled with some of
the best players in the world
genn made top eight oh man so scary or
bad position
but the slide that switched positions
rage oh if you range out of there out of
the time he's living
last time stomp on him oh dow jab
can't stay in a live state clutch there
man that guy's scary
maybe slow down a little bit on some of
these mix-ups just use some of the basic
tools and safer tools
hey that should be the game
if he got this column
yeah he knew that unscathed holy crap oh
what the hell combo not sure
gotta try the sides up here and the
damage is adding up oh you're right
that's off already
he's already up standing up but despite
his great showing at evo japan
genn's performance had an asterisk next
to it
leeroy you you did a block earlier right
yeah so how was that i was stuck over
here doing bb tag while you were then
doing tekken so
what what happened i know leroy right
that's the man of the hour right now
yeah is it true i think look i ain't
gonna say he's
he's too good but he's definitely too
good pre-patch leroy who
many call the most broken character
tekken has ever seen
was playable at evo japan and many
players
including genn dropped their manes to
pick up the busted alternative
oh wow
oh you're dead hella dead getting top 8
at evo japan is hard no matter what
but some people felt that getting top 8
with leroy was
a little less impressive people were
accusing leroy players of getting
carried by the character but genn
continued to make noise
helping his team win the 2020 tekken pro
championship japan vs korea
but then ken's momentum crashed to a
halt
the global pandemic put the competitive
tekken scene on pause because of the
risks associated with putting a bunch of
players in the same room for an entire
weekend
and because tekken's net code is less
than optimal
the competitive scene came to a
standstill but
in june almost half a year after evo
japan
genn made his return to competitive
tekken once again
tapanga league tekken 7 was a two-part
16 player japanese tournament
in the first part the players would play
on a line but the top six
would advance to an offline final and
topanga league featured stiff
competition
huge names like ao rangchu and of course
the reigning tekken world tour champion
chikurin
advancing past the online group stage
gen's real test
came in the finals and the dude aced it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
going undefeated to win the topanga
league and earning his very own
giant check
genn's journey has been long and filled
with highs and
lows he's battled and beaten legends
he's left the game
entirely and returned even stronger a
year later
and the best part is at 19 years old
ken's story is still
just beginning he has plenty of years
ahead of him to sharpen his skills and
create his
own legend thanks for watching if you
want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you